>>> AS WE CONTINUE OUR "SPRING
INTO SUMMER" SERIES, WE LOOK AT
WHAT TO EXPECT WHEN YOU MAKE
SUMMER PLANS.
FOR MANY FAMILIES, SUMMER MEANS
A TRIP TO THE BEACH.
JANET SHAMLIAN FOUND OUT HOW
COASTAL COMMUNITIES LIKE
GALVESTON, TEXAS, ARE RECOVERING
FROM THE PANDEMIC.
>> Reporter: BEACH-GOERS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE READY TO EMBRACE
THE SUMMER NICED LAST SUMMER.
HERE -- MISSED LAST SUMMER.
HERE IN GALVESTON THEY LOST A
MILLION VISITORS IN 2020, BUT
THEY'RE OPTIMISTIC THIS SEASON
WILL RETURN TO PRE-COVID LEVELS.
AND WITH 32 MILES OF SAND AND
SURF, THERE'S PLENTY OF ROOM FOR
COASTAL DISTANCING.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO STAY ON THE
SAND.
THE PLEASURE PIER HAS GAMES,
FOOD, AND AMUSEMENT RIDES.
THE GALAXY WHEEL OFFERS SOME
AMAZING VIEWS OF THE GULF, AND
IT WILL BE OPEN SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK STARTING ON MEMORIAL DAY
WEEKEND.
THERE ARE DOZENS OF HOTELS HERE
WHICH ARE SEEING ROOMS FILL TO
ALMOST PRE-PANDEMIC OCCUPANCY.
BUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY, ANALYSTS
PREDICT IT WILL BE A COUPLE OF
YEARS BEFORE HOTELS FILL TO 2019
LEVELS.
GOOD FOOD IS A BIG PART OF A
BEACH TRIP.
WHILE TEXAS DOES NOT HAVE A
MASKING REQUIREMENT, SOME
RESTAURANTS DO.
OWNERS SAY COME DURING THE WEEK
IF YOU WANT TO AVOID CROWDS.
AS TOURISTS COME BACK, GALVESTON
NEEDS WORKERS.
WHY THE SHORTAGE?
BEACH TOWNS FROM THE JERSEY
SHORE TO THE OREGON COAST CLAIM
EVERYTHING FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS TO TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS,
MAKING IT TOUGH FOR TEMPORARY
WORKERS FROM OTHER COUNTRIES TO
GET HERE.
AND SOME TOURIST SPOTS WERE
OFFERING BONUSES TO FILL
HUNDREDS OF JOBS.
WHETHER FOR WORK OR PLAY, THE
TEXAS GULF COAST IS READY TO
WELCOME PEOPLE BAC